So how are we going to do this?
Well, it's not going to surprise you.
We're going to use principle component
analysis because when you see a picture
that looks like this,
where I want the extended dimension,
I want to use that extended variance.
So here's how we're going to do
principle component analysis for this.
Assume we have M data points, okay?
So x1 through xM.
Alright, where they are in
some D dimensional space.
R to the D.
Where D is big, really big.
At least 10,000.
Maybe it's a million, okay,
so if I had a 1k by 1k image.
That would be a million pixels, so
I have a million dimensional space.
So, what we want is some
direction in that big space,
that captures most of the variation.
Okay?
And furthermore, and
this is sort of important.
Not sort of important,
this is really important.
If I talk about a direction, and
let's suppose u as my direction.
How would I find out
where it lies along that?
Well, whats nice about this is because
we're doing everything linearly
we're just going to take the dot
product of x minus its mean.
Why are we subtracting the mean?
because none of this stuff works
if you don't subtract the mean.
Remember, we're doing
variation about the mean.
So we subtract the mean and
we take the dot product, and
then u X of,
u of X i that would be the coefficient.
So we want to find the u that
captures most of the variance.
All right, well you know already how to
do this because we've been talking about
it right, so here's this same
expression that we had before, but
I sort of used the notation
we just developed, right?
We have, we're going to say,
the variance along u.
Well we want it over all
the possible points.
So what we say is okay, well we're
just going to take that average.
Here is x minus mu.
Dotted with u,
we multiply it also by its transpose.
So that we get the square value.
Okay, so that's just the same thing
that we had from the previous slide,
I'm just going to rearrange
that a little bit.
Right, so
I can pull the U's out here, and
the, the another U out there
because it's transpose, transpose.
And what I have left here in the middle,
well what is that?
Right, that's just
the covariance matrix and
we'll call it the covariance
matrix sigmund.
We've talked about how for
finding this, the axis of,
of, maximum variance,
we need that covariance matrix.
But think about this
just a little bit more.
So that variance of u is u
transpose sigma u, all right?